your film a stone cold Christmas
was that a business decision or was that
something you felt compelled to write it
was completely a business decision so at
that point I hadn't written or directed
anything on a professional level quite
yet
and initially because of my hip-hop
musical short film
I was hired by the by the network to
write a Christmas musical
but they wanted to get done in a short
amount of time period
so we didn't have enough time to do all
that because with the musical you have
all these other things you have to worry
about rehearsals for dancers
um you know sessions for the singers
actors music you got to make so it's
it's a longer laborious situation so
they wanted something a little bit
quicker so they came up with the idea of
the Devil Wears Prada
me to Christmas Carol
and that's basically what that was and
so
um we actually already had a script done
that was at Christmas music we it was a
finished script that we done and then
we're like you know what we can't do
this so
can we do this
so like yeah I guess so so we went ahead
and you know took took their information
took their notes and then we created our
outline we created a beat sheet first
then our outlined and then from there
went ahead and started writing and you
know the first in about two or three
weeks we had our first draft got some
notes back kept getting it better and
Tighter and what have you and that's
what happened but yeah that was
completely a uh that was a money grab I
mean that was my first opportunity for a
job and you kind of do what you need to
do so you know Christmas movies are a
great way to kind of get into the
business if you don't if you never sold
a script before
hey were you aware because I I'm just
now seeing the the impact of Christmas
films I mean I keep hearing about them
for years but it really is that there's
so many different takes on sort of the
Christmas love story yeah and and it's
fascinating yeah were you were you so
tuned in or dis this dialed you in this
this situation this uh this opportunity
dialed me into the fact that there's a
lot of uh opportunity for Christmas
movies and so no I had no idea about
them I never really even watched the
Christmas movie before honestly uh
because we all know that it's all pretty
much the same beats the same tropes
um and so
it was nothing that I would ever watch
um however after writing one
selling it directing it
and then running another one which ended
up on Lifetime I think a year later I'm
like okay
there is a business here and so when I
looked and I reached back and I'm like
you know I think there's something like
60 to 70 new Christmas movies made every
single year that are you know that's
shown on Lifetime and Hallmark and ion
and bounce and all these other networks
um even Netflix is now getting into it
you know so there is every single year
there is a rich opportunity of selling
these movies and so I keep telling all
my friends I've never
um sold a script before I'm like you
want to sell a script write one of these
like go watch a few learn the Beats it's
all the same stuff I mean I could
literally give you the point my portal
that's all the same stuff
learn it and then go write it but put
your little twist on it you know so that
way you won't like
get bored or go crazy with it because
they they can be boring to write
what if someone says you know I I'm not
going to do that I want to be Paul
Thomas Anderson I want to be John
Singleton I want to have a certain take
and I don't want to do the same Trope of
a woman discovers love through in the
holiday season and sees whatever her
life is and changes it so what do you
tell someone like that yeah that's a
very good question if somebody wants to
you know switch it up and do something
that's quite different than what the
typical tropes are you know okay this is
I'll give you I'll give you the business
piece and then I'll give you the
artistic piece the business piece is
you know the customer is always right
if the customer wants a woman
two goes back to her old hometown
finds you know hooks up with her an old
fling Falls in loves discovers love you
know loses the guy wins him back kisses
and the snow falls in the end with the
dog by her feet
they're paying for it give them what
they want
that's the business side of me and you
can make a killing doing that because
like I said there's so many of these
every single year the artistic side says
if you want to do something different
you want to go ahead and mix it up a
little bit be something that typically
is not done go write it but don't expect
to sell it go write it you know I
wouldn't expect it to sell that because
that's not what they're asking for the
customer is always right they're the
ones flipping the bill
and they know what they want they know
their audience they've done this for a
lot a long time
longer than you now if you want to go
make it and then you know go financing
yourself or raise the money and go shoot
yourself and then try to sell it or or
put it on you know a a pvod situation
then great go do it but if you like if
you're trying to get it to Lifetime and
Hallmark and ion and all the other ones
they know what they want in fact there's
mandates they literally give you this
you know 12-page document regarding what
they're looking for what has to happen
and if you don't give them that they're
not going to buy it so you kind of have
to look at it from the business
standpoint they know their audience
could I get that from their website no
okay they don't give the Mandate of the
Mandate on the website you get it
um through
people that have worked with them in the
past that know it that have given it
like I have one because somebody give it
to me
um or if you get hired for a job
um then they'll give it to you
this is what we want it to be so let's
say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna write a
Christmas movie let me I want to try it
and and I'm not gonna just my heart's
gonna be in it as much as it can be
knowing that it might be a money grab
but I have a few cute stories what
what's the route to getting it to
someone there so I spend time I've had
people review it I think it's in good
shape
easy the easiest route to do it is to is
to work with somebody a producer that
has worked with them in the past
and they'll go ahead and get it to them
oh because because typically the way it
works is so Avid is I'm an executive
producer friend of mine who has um a
deal with different Networks and the
deals typically are more than one movie
they're like a three-picture deal
so in these three picture deals that may
include a Christmas movie a thriller you
know a woman in power woman in Peril as
they said used to say a movie
um
they they typically is not or not just
one-offs so
um if unless they have something already
in their pipeline which also happens a
lot where they've already are developing
this this executive producers already
developing something with somebody else
um you know if if you are able to
connect with them and say hey look I
have some Christmas movie scripts done
you know like here's the craziest thing
I've never seen this before and again
I'm I'm new in this business three years
in but
you know once um covet began
and
she
the the the system shut down and nobody
was shooting anything
I got hit up so many times by people
saying hey do you have any scripts do
you have any scripts do you have any
completed projects any completed
projects because they were looking for
content
so we know that that there's a need for
this kind of content
so yeah I would just say hey go look go
look at a few movies on some of these
networks see who the producers were hit
them up this is what I this is what I do
all the time hit them up and be like hey
look I know you did this I love the
movie like give them some love I love
the movie you guys were amazing
um I have a script
that's already completed
and you know I won't tell you what it's
about because I know you probably don't
have you know you probably have a no
solicitation situation there but I want
to be able to get this to you what's the
best way to do that and I would do it
that way now I mean it's harder if you
don't have a um
a manager already
uh but if you do
um you can have the manager get in
contact and do that same work for you
so make sure these are finished scripts
it's not just a treatment it's not just
an idea these are finished people have
reviewed them you've checked them for
errors okay and and if you don't have a
manager and or an agent are you finding
them through IMDb Pro IMDb Pro literally
is that so look at look at again you
want to go with a person that has
already put the work in that already has
a relationship with these networks
um yeah and I would totally do that I'll
go through I may be Pro find the
producer
uh because a lot of them were like I
mean they working but they're not like
famous so it's like you know they'll
take a phone call or an email
and then you know don't send them the
product because they you know because
they don't want to have unsolicited
stuff you want to communicate first
what's going on here and say hey look
you know this is what I have
I have one or two you know scripts
um definitely in line with what you've
done in the past with this network
and then go back and forth and try to
work it out and as an independent
filmmaker artist do we tend to make some
of those too edgy like how do we how do
we make them more mainstream because I
can imagine if I wrote something I'd
probably that the notes would be it's
it's not it's not gonna work it's to
whatever and I have to make it more
corporate so to speak yeah how can I as
someone who's more quirky make it more
corporate so that it's more salable
that's a very good question how to make
it more corporate
um number one that's
probably my number one reason why I
don't like to write them because I am an
edgy guy when it comes to my writing not
in real life I'm very just quiet in real
life but
writing wise I like
you know I like craziness so
yeah
the best way to do it honestly is to go
look and see what was been you know
what's been done before and look at and
look at those beats I'm really you know
I'm really big into looking at the Beats
understanding what's going on this is
the point when they meet this is the
meet cute moment this is the point when
and look at how they're talking to each
other I mean of course you'll have your
own words your own dialogue but
you know they're never going to meet at
a strip club like that's not what
lifetime does you know it's Christmas
time she's wearing a you know she's
wearing a Santa hat I would write that
but that's not what's going to sell to
them so you have to have some situations
so they're going to meet someplace in
town you know puppies or a bakery or you
know they're they're doing the you know
the Christmas decorations at a hotel
but then finally a little twist to it
you know you got to find your your
twists are going to come
are going to come in
in maybe taking some of the tropes that
we've seen before
and doing something like going left when
people typically go right you know
um we think that the first guy that she
meets is going to be her lover you know
or the person that she's going to fall
in love with but maybe maybe it's not
him maybe it's another person maybe I
mean I'm even these days I'm starting to
see you know it seem see see more
same-sex ones you know maybe it's a girl
you know so it depends on what they're
looking for of course
um but yeah so I mean
you want to study what's already being
done and then understand that and then
you can play in the sandbox
character Arc is the protagonist in a
Christmas film having
yeah there's different ones typically
the most typical one is a person who
um
liked Christmas at one time doesn't like
Christmas anymore and now falls in love
with Christmas again
uh that's one typical one another one
could be a person who once was in love
had her heart hurt fell out of love and
now she's falling in love again those
are the typical ones
um that someone's like I I'm not kidding
when I say it's pretty much the same
Beats the question is where do you put
it you know whether you put it in a
castle with a prince and a princess or a
Layman and a princess or a Layman and a
prince
um it's still the same beats you know
this fish out of water goes into this
area that they meet somebody and they
fall in love but you know in the very
beginning they kind of butt heads a
little bit and then but through that
process they begin to to respect each
other and fall in love with each other
oh but then there's some you know some X
that comes in to town and now this
ex-boyfriend ex-girlfriend situation is
gonna threaten to mess it up the
situation but then you know and then as
a result of that they lose this newfound
love but then they they do everything
they can to win them back and they by
the end they win them back
so the ending always has to be a happy
ending always a happy always always
happy you will not sell non a non-happy
eating so and it can't be something
that's a little bit where this it's a
vague ending it has to be very clear-cut
very clear-cut interesting yeah I know
it's crazy but that's what they want and
do do you study the demographic of the
average Christmas uh viewer Christmas
movie viewer yeah
in regards to the demographic of the
average Christmas viewer I mean it's you
know think of the networks that they're
on they're usually on a lifetime or
Hallmark who's watching those those
movies you know female probably you know
late 20s between you know 29 and 45. you
know that's that's who it's for so you
know the guy you want the guys to be hot
you know you want the girls to be
flawed but lovable you know what does
that mean what is flawed but lovable
they make mistakes you know they do
things they you know they're a little
bit too caring they're a little bit too
into Christmas
um or or or they've given up on life I'm
not life but love you know if they're
giving up on Christmas
but then through the process they learn
to fall in love with that again right
right and they always have the perfect
house and the perfect hair
I'd love to see one with messy hair
hair don't know if they'll do that but
yeah I guess it depends on where you
know a person with messy hair where
would you place that out you know a hair
salon if you did a Christmas movie at a
hair salon you see it has to be organic
still so you it could probably actually
that might I've never seen that before
that might actually work there you go uh
a Christmas movie at a hair salon you
know this hair salon is is maybe it's um
I don't know they're losing his
Christmas spirit or they're about to
lose it because they can't make enough
money or you know there's there's a lot
of ways that you could take that right
an evil developer comes and wants and
they're they're out on their lease and
and then it turns out the evil
developer's son
and and he makes her believe in
Christmas again there you go or love
again I mean all that literally that
that literally is how it works right
like you
you look okay I know what I need to do I
know these beats I need to have I know
the exciting internet I know the
midpoint I know that All Is Lost you
know I know the beginning and I know the
end like to me that's how I do my
scripts I like I start from the end like
when I want them to end up and then I
make them the exact opposite in the
beginning and that's how I know I'll
have an arc interesting okay and she's
about to lose release on December 26th
yes and so right there you go there you
go add water and stir